This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. As the sun set that April evening, the wireless radio began to crackle. It was a cold night in the North Atlantic, and ships were sending messages to their sisters. Watch out, they said. Icebergs ahead. On board the RMS Titanic, a man named Jack Phillips was working at the wireless radio. He received word from another ship that pinpointed the location of heavy ice pack and a great number of burgs. Close to 11 p.m., another ship, the Californian, said it had come to a standstill in a dense field of ice. Shut up, the wireless operator is supposed to have responded.
这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。四月那个傍晚太阳落山时，无线电台开始发出刺啦的杂音。北大西洋的夜晚十分寒冷，各艘船只正在向它们的姊妹船发送消息。小心，它们说。前方有冰山。在“泰坦尼克号”客轮上，一个名叫杰克·菲利普斯的男子正在无线电台工作。他收到另一艘船发来的消息，精确指出了厚冰区和大量冰山的所在地。接近晚上11点时，另一艘船“加利福尼亚号”称它在一片密集的冰区中停了下来。闭嘴，无线电操作员据说这样回复道。
I'm busy. Busy with what? Jack Phillips was sending and receiving personal messages over the wireless radio for the ship's many wealthy and important passengers. You know what happened next. The Titanic struck an iceberg shortly afterwards. It sank and killed more than 1,500 people on board.
我很忙。忙什么呢？杰克·菲利普斯正在通过无线电为船上许多富有且重要的乘客发送和接收私人信件。你知道接下来发生了什么。不久之后，“泰坦尼克号”撞上了一座冰山。它沉没了，导致船上1500多人丧生。
Today we know there were many things that went wrong that night in 1912. People mistakenly believed that Titanic was unsinkable. There were not enough lifeboats to go around. The lifeboats that did manage to get into the water eventually floated away with more than 400 empty seats. But the story of what happened in the wireless room that night is less well known. What might have happened if the wireless operator, the captain and crew had actually listened to the warnings that were coming in loud and clear. Today on the show, we explore a great psychological mystery. We've all been provided with a plethora of ways to understand what other people are telling us.
今天我们知道，1912年那晚出了很多差错。人们误以为“泰坦尼克号”永不沉没。救生艇数量不足。那些好不容易被放入水中的救生艇最终飘走时，上面还有400多个空座位。但那天晚上无线电室里究竟发生了什么，这个故事却不为人所知。如果无线电操作员、船长和船员真的听取了那些清晰响亮的警告，可能会发生什么呢？今天的节目中，我们将探讨一个巨大的心理学谜题。我们所有人都获得了大量的方式来理解别人在对我们说的话。
Why do we so often fail to take heed? The science of learning and the art of listening, this week on Hidden Brain. There are lots of reasons two people might misunderstand each other, but nearly all of them are either caused or compounded by a single factor. One or both parties has failed to hear what the other is actually saying. You see this in classrooms, in workplaces, in geopolitical settings. It happens between strangers, between partners, between friends. At the University of Haifa in Israel, psychologist Guy Itzikoff studies the science of listening. Guy Itzikoff, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi Shankar, great to be here.
为什么我们经常没有听进去呢？学习的科学与倾听的艺术，本周《隐藏的大脑》。两个人可能会互相误解，原因有很多，但几乎所有这些原因都是由单一因素引起的或加剧的。其中一方或双方没有听到对方真正在说什么。你在教室、工作场所、地缘政治环境中都能看到这一点。这种情况发生在陌生人之间、伴侣之间、朋友之间。在以色列海法大学，心理学家盖伊·伊齐科夫研究倾听的科学。盖伊·伊齐科夫，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嗨，尚卡尔，很高兴来到这里。
Guy, I want to take you back to when you were 22 years old. You once got into an argument with a very good friend. Who was this friend, Guy? How long had you known him? I've known him since kindergarten. Okay. So, this is a longstanding friendship. So, what happened?
盖伊，我想把你带回你22岁的时候。你曾和一个很好的朋友争吵过。盖伊，这个朋友是谁？你认识他多久了？我从幼儿园就认识他了。好的。所以，这是一段长久的友谊。那么，发生了什么？
What caused the conflict? It was a lot of time ago. Now, I'm 38 now, so it seems like a different, you know, a different lifetime. But I wasn't invited to a social event that I really wanted to be invited to. Many of the popular kids were there. And I was never, not unpopular, but never in the popular group. And this friend was friends with some people in the popular group. And the couple of days after I heard someone talking about this event.
是什么引发了冲突？那是很久以前的事了。我现在38岁了，所以这看起来像是一个不同的，你知道的，不同的人生阶段。但我没有被邀请参加一个我真的很想去的社交活动。许多受欢迎的孩子都在那里。而我从来都不是——倒也不是不受欢迎，但从来不在受欢迎的群体里。这个朋友和受欢迎群体里的一些人是朋友。在那之后的两三天，我听到有人在谈论这个活动。
And it didn't really did anything to me until I heard this friend was there. My friend was there. And, and I thought that he did not tell me about this event, even though he was my best friend. This is what I thought initially, and I felt really, really insulted. Yeah, did you confront your friend or did you just simply stew in silence?
直到我听说这个朋友也在那儿之前，这并没有对我的情绪产生真正的触动。我的朋友在那儿。然后，我认为他没有告诉我这个活动，尽管他是我最好的朋友。我最初就是这么想的，我觉得自己真的、真的很受侮辱。是的，你是去质问你的朋友，还是只是默默地生闷气？
So I played passive aggressive for a while. So I said, okay, I'm gonna play insulted. So I didn't answer his phone, his calls. And so I avoided him for a few days until we eventually met in an unplanned way for me. And what happened at this meeting? So he came to me and I was very cold. I wanted him to understand that I'm angry. Yeah.
所以我有一段时间表现得很消极攻击。我说，好吧，我要装作受了侮辱的样子。所以我没有接他的电话，他的呼叫。所以我避开他几天，直到我们最终以一种我意料之外的方式相遇。这次见面发生了什么？所以他朝我走来，我表现得很冷淡。我希望他明白我在生气。是的。
And he was like, okay, so what's your problem? Why are you being so distant and cold? And, and what did they do to you? Um, and then I, I vented about him not inviting me or telling me about this, this event. I was like, how could he not invite me? Like I always invite him to other events like this. And when he gets the chance, he doesn't reciprocate and that he used this as an opportunity to be more in the popular group. After so long, it's hard to remember the words,
然后他说，好吧，那你的问题是什么？你为什么这么疏远和冷淡？而且，你对我做了什么？嗯，然后我向他倾诉了他没有邀请我或告诉我这个活动。我当时想，他怎么能不邀请我呢？就像我总是邀请他参加其他这样的活动一样。当他有机会时，他却不投桃报李，而且他利用这个机会更好地融入受欢迎的群体。事隔太久，很难记清具体的话，
but I remember the feeling. Yeah. You were hurt and you felt wounded and betrayed and you wanted him to understand how upset you were. Exactly. Exactly. I didn't even want an apology. I wanted to make him feel like I felt. Did he try and explain what happened, Guy? Yeah. So he was saying words in the beginning. I had no idea what he said because I was to be busy listening to myself. But when I get angry, I have a tendency to repeat the same thing over and over and over again. And after a few repetitions, I suddenly became aware that he's saying, you got
但我记得那种感觉。是的。你受到了伤害，感到心碎和背叛，你想让他明白你有多难过。完全正确。完全正确。我甚至不想要道歉。我想让他感受一下我的感受。盖伊，他有没有试图解释发生了什么？是的。开始时他说了一些话。我根本不知道他说的是什么，因为我太忙于听自己说话了。但当我生气时，我有把同一句话重复了一遍又一遍又一遍的倾向。重复了几次后，我突然意识到他在说，你完全
it completely wrong. I did call you. I did text you. And then I called him a liar. You got it completely wrong. I did call you. I did text you. And then I called him a liar. Not only did you not invite with me, but you also are lying to me. The friend pulled out his phone and showed Guy
弄错了。我确实给你打过电话。我确实给你发过短信。然后我骂他是骗子。你完全弄错了。我确实给你打过电话。我确实给你发过短信。然后我骂他是骗子。你不仅不邀请我，你还在对我说谎。朋友掏出手机，向盖伊
the message he had sent, the call he had made. And then Guy remembered. He had recently switched phones because his battery had died. His phone had been out of commission when his friend had tried to reach him. I felt so, so small. I felt like, wow, I completely misread the situation. I completely judged him without having, like giving him the opportunity to explain it, and he was actually right. And I felt really bad about it afterwards.
展示了他发送的信息、他拨打的电话。然后盖伊想起来了。他最近换了手机，因为他的电池没电了。当他的朋友试图联系他时，他的手机一直处于无法使用状态。我感到自己好小、好渺小。我觉得，哇，我完全误解了情况。我完全没有给对方解释的机会就妄加判断，而他其实是对的。事后我为此感到非常糟糕。
Some time later, after Guy became a psychologist, he got to experience what it felt like when the shoe was on the other foot. He was working with a colleague in the field of education on a project. His colleague decided to bring in a senior scholar from his field. But when Guy and his colleague went to meet the other researcher, the senior scholar ignored him. He had no interest in listening to Guy or hearing about what he might bring to the project. My friend and I are about the same age. His colleague is older than I, than both of us. And like he looks, I felt like he's looking through me
一段时间后，在盖伊成为心理学家之后，他体验到了风水轮流转的滋味。他和教育领域的以为同事合作一个项目。他的同事决定从他的领域引进一位资深学者。但当盖伊和同事去见另一位研究人员时，这位资深学者却忽视了他。他对倾听盖伊或了解盖伊能为这个项目带来什么毫无兴趣。我和我的同事年龄相仿。他的同事比我年长，比我们俩都年长。而且他的眼神，我感觉他像是在透过我看
and he actually said, well, why do you need him for? Get someone from our own college. And I felt so insulted. Like he literally said, looked at me and said, why do you need him for? Like I don't exist, why do you need him for? Like, I don't exist, why do you need him for? And the truth is, I think as human beings, we are incredibly sensitive to these markers
他居然说，你还要他干什么？从我们自己的学院找个人就行了。我觉得太受侮辱了。就像他字面意思那样，看着我说，你还要他干什么？就像我根本不存在一样，你还要他干什么？就像我根本不存在一样，你还要他干什么？但事实是，我认为作为人类，我们对这些社会拒绝的标志
of social rejection. In fact, even with the first story you told me about the party, part of the reason you were angry was that you wanted to be part of this group and the group wasn't, you'd felt that you weren't being welcomed into the group. And in this case, you were, you wanted to be part of this grand proposal and this person was rejecting you.
极其敏感。事实上，即使是你讲的关于派对的第一个故事，你生气的部分原因也是因为你想成为这个群体的一部分，而这个群体没有，你觉得你没有被欢迎进入这个群体。而在这种情况下，你是，你想成为这个宏大提案的一部分，而这个人却在拒绝你。
And as human beings, I think we're extraordinarily sensitive to any signal that someone actually might be dissing us, ignoring us, rejecting us. Of course, it's a basic human need. The need to belong, the need to feel included and to be connected with other people. It goes with us through early childhood to our entire life. Yeah, yeah. I'm wondering, do you see examples of poor listening as you look around you, not just in your own life, Guy, but when you look at the media, on cable TV,
作为人类，我认为我们对任何人可能在贬低我们、忽视我们、拒绝我们的任何信号都异常敏感。当然，这是一种基本的人类需求。归属感的需求，感到被包容以及与他人建立联系的需求。它伴随我们从幼儿期到整个人生。是的，是的。我在想，当你环顾四周时，是否看到了糟糕倾听的例子，不仅是在你自己的生活中，盖伊，当你看看媒体、有线电视，
faculty meetings, cabinet meetings, do you see examples of poor listening everywhere you look? Well, to remind you, I live in Israel, so I see more example of poor listening than the other way around. There is a sentence saying, two Israelis, four opinions. So unfortunately, I see poor listening everywhere. and even more unfortunately, it seems to be escalating as time goes by.
教职员会议、内阁会议，你到处都能看到糟糕倾听的例子吗？嗯，提醒你一下，我住在以色列，所以我看到的糟糕倾听的例子比其他任何地方都要多。有这样一句话，两个以色列人，四种意见。所以不幸的是，我到处都能看到糟糕倾听的现象。更不幸的是，随着时间的推移，这种现象似乎还在升级。
Nowadays, with the televisions, at least in Israel, this is how I feel. So, the norm unfortunately became to bring someone and start arguing with them. So if you don't argue with them, it's not interesting. It's all about the arguing and the yelling and who yells stronger and who's who dominates the conversation and, uh, two people yell. So the one that you hear is the person who yells the loudest. This is what I talk about, a toxic atmosphere. It's always like, let's bring someone from the opposite that we disagree with and see and get them start yelling and then we will respond. And
现在，通过电视，至少在以色列，我的感觉是这样。所以不幸的是，现在的规范变成了把某人请来然后开始和他们争论。所以如果你不和他们争论，那就没有意思了。一切都是关于争吵、尖叫，谁叫得更大声，谁主导了对话，嗯，两个人都在吵。所以你能听到的人就是那个叫得最大声的人。这就是我所说的有毒的氛围。总是像，让我们把一个我们不同意的对立面的人请来，然后让他们开始尖叫，接着我们再回应。然后，
as a listening researcher, this really, I get a bad feeling from listening to it. When we come back, how poor listening ruins conversations and undermines our relationships, and how to learn to listen better. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. The social psychologist James Spennebaker said, conversations are like dances. Two people effortlessly move in step with one another, usually anticipating the other person's next move. Now good conversations might feel this way, but very often in our discussions with others,
作为一名倾听研究人员，这真的，听起来让我感觉很糟糕。当我们回来时，糟糕的倾听如何毁掉对话并破坏我们的人际关系，以及如何学会更好地倾听。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。社会心理学家詹姆斯·佩内贝克说，对话就像舞蹈。两个人毫不费力地步调一致，通常能预测到对方的下一步动作。现在，好的对话可能会有这种感觉，但在我们与他人的讨论中，
it can feel like we have two left feet. At the University of Haifa, Guy Itzikov studies the psychology of listening. He says that listening plays a bigger role in conversations than we imagine. Guy, it seems like listening should be the easiest thing in the world. Someone speaks, all you have to do is sit there and pay attention. You see that one thing that makes it hard to do this well is that many of us are juggling a lot. We suffer from a chronic lack of bandwidth?
我们经常会感觉自己像长了两只左脚。在海法大学，盖伊·伊齐科夫研究倾听心理学。他说，倾听在对话中发挥的作用比我们想象的要大得多。盖伊，听起来倾听应该是世界上最简单的事情。有人说话，你所要看到的只是坐在那里注意听。你认为做好这件事很难的一个原因是，我们许多人都在同时应付很多事情。我们遭受着带宽的长期匮乏？
Yes, exactly, because listening is not that easy. Listening is costly. It requires motivation. It requires cognitive ability. It requires time and effort. And these is resources, there are limited resources that we have and we need to decide how to allocate them. You know, like the famous sentence, time is money.
是的，完全如此，因为倾听并没有那么简单。倾听是有代价的。它需要动力。它需要认知能力。它需要时间和精力。而这些资源，是我们拥有的有限资源，我们需要决定如何分配它们。你知道，就像那句名言，时间就是金钱。
And I think the reason that we think that listening is easy is often that we confuse listening with being silent, which is also not easy all the time, but listening is much harder than merely being silent. I'm imagining settings like a workplace, for example, where there's a lot of things going on, maybe a high-pressure environment. It's very difficult in those situations to actually make time to listen to someone
我认为我们认为倾听很容易的原因，往往是我们把倾听与保持沉默混淆了，保持沉默也并非随时都很容易，但倾听比单纯保持沉默要困难得多。我在想象诸如工作场所这样的环境，比如说，那里有很多事情在发生，也许是一个高压环境。在那种情况下，要真正腾出时间去倾听某人是非常困难的
because there's so much going on that you feel, you know, okay, I'm happy to have a conversation with you, but the conversation needs to be 60 seconds because that's all the time that I have. And of course, when you put that kind of constraint on the conversation, it makes it very hard for the person to speak or for you to listen. That's true. And in addition to it, think about the time when an employee of yours or maybe you or towards your supervisor came and said, well, I really need to talk to you. And even though you only had 60 seconds, but in addition, your mind wasn't clean to listen. You were bothered by your next meeting or your previous conversation or a million other
因为有太多事情在发生，以至于你觉得，你知道的，我很高兴和你交谈，但对话必须在60秒内结束，因为这就是我拥有的全部时间。当然，当你在对话中施加这种限制时，就会使对方很难开口说话，或者让你很难倾听。确实如此。除此之外，想象一下这样的时刻，你的一个员工，或者也许是你，或者针对你的主管走过来对我说，嗯，我真的需要和你谈谈。尽管你只有60秒的时间，但不仅如此，你的大脑并没有清空来倾听。你被你的下一个会议、你之前的对话或无数其他
things. This is why we talk about the ability, the cognitive ability. So you might have even, you might even have 60 seconds, you might have 10 minutes, but your internal disturbances would prevent you from really listening to this person. Has this ever happened to you, Guy? Can you think of a time when someone came to you and wanted to talk with you, but in fact, you had so much going on in your own head that, in fact, even though you were, quote, unquote,
事情所困扰。这就是我们讨论能力、认知能力的原因。所以你可能甚至，你可能甚至有60秒，你可能有10分钟，但你内部的干扰会阻止你真正倾听这个人。盖伊，这在你身上发生过吗？你能想到什么时候有人来找你想和你谈谈，但实际上，你自己的脑子里有太多事情在进行，以至于即使你，姑且称之为，
listening, you weren't really listening? Yes, yes. I have three girls. My little one is in the Hadar, is in the first grade. My little one, Michal, is in the fourth grade. And my older one, Noor, is in the Hadar is in the first grade. My middle one, Michal is in the fourth grade and my older one is in the sixth grade. Um, and, uh, so, you know, as, as, as a father with three girls and my wife, I live with four women, so I'm constantly reminded that I need to be a better
在倾听，你其实并没有真正在倾听？是的，是的。我有三个女孩。我的小女儿在读一年级。我的小女儿米哈尔在四年级。我的大女儿努尔在读一年级。我的二女儿米哈尔在四年级，我的大女儿在六年级。嗯，所以，你知道，作为一个有三个女孩的父亲和我的妻子，我和四个女人生活在一起，所以我不断被提醒我需要成为一个更好的
listener. But one, one, one story that really strikes me, um, it was an experience that, um, with Michal, with my middle one, and when she was in kindergarten and we went to the playground, um, and, you know, as an academic, I have a job that I often, I work from home. So work home balance is really, the line is really fuzzy. So work home balance is really, the line is really fuzzy. And so it was me and her and you know, she was on the swing. And I was texting work things and, and she talked and I, you know, I was texting and like two minutes after she said, daddy, I want to go up.
倾听者。但有一个，有一个，有一个故事真的让我印象深刻，嗯，那是一段经历，嗯，关于米哈尔，我的二女儿，当她在幼儿园时，我们去了游乐场，嗯，你知道的，作为一个学者，我的工作使得我经常在家办公。所以工作与生活的平衡真的是，界限真的很模糊。所以工作与生活的平衡真的是，界限真的很模糊。当时我和她在一起，你知道的，她在荡秋千。而我在用手机发工作的事情，而且，她说话而我，你知道的，我在发短信，大约在她说完两分钟后，爸爸，我想上去。
She wanted to go home. She wanted to go home. Yeah. Go up here because we live in the apartment. We live in the building and the apartment. Daddy, I want to go up to home. And she really wanted to go to the playground before. And then I caught myself like, wow, I'm so, I'm a, I study listening and this is
她想回家。她想回家。yeah。上去这里，因为我们住在公寓里。我们住在大楼和公寓里。爸爸，我想回家。她之前真的很想去游乐场。然后我突然意识到，哇，我太，我研究倾听，这也是
what I do, so yeah, I have all the excuses in the world. And I put the phone in my pocket and then without the phone that after a few minutes I asked her, Michal, do you still want to go up? She said no. This is just one example. When Guy was distracted, his daughter instantly picked up on it. Researchers have tested the same effect in the lab. In a study led by Munisha Pasupathi at the University of Utah, people were paired up in conversation.
我的工作，所以是的，我有世上所有的借口。然后我把手机放进口袋里，没有了手机，几分钟后我问她，米哈尔，你还想上去吗？她说不。这只是一个例子。当盖伊分心时，他的女儿立刻察觉到了这一点。研究人员在实验室里测试了相同的效应。在犹他大学的莫尼沙·帕苏帕蒂领导的一项研究中，人们被配对进行对话。
Some of the listeners were given good listening instructions. Listen like you would listen to a close friend. But then there was a second condition. So there are numerous experiments using distractions where listeners were distracted. A great research by Monisha Pasopathy from the University of Utah, they brought participants to the laboratory.
一些倾听者得到了良好的倾听指导。像倾听密友那样去倾听。但随后还有第二个条件。所以有大量使用干扰的实验，其中倾听者分心了。来自犹他大学的莫尼沙·帕苏帕蒂做了一项很棒的研究，他们把参与者带到实验室。
And they divided them to pairs, two diets, listener and a speaker. You either were in the listener role or in the speaker role. And your instruction as a listener was to listen like you listen to a close friend. The speaker told you about a meaningful event that happened to them. And you were told to, as a listener, to listen like you listen to a close friend. In the distraction condition, the listeners were giving the same instructions but were also told, count the number of times that the speaker
并把他们分成对，两个双人组，倾听者和说话者。你要么扮演倾听者的角色，要么扮演说话者的角色。作为倾听者的指导是像倾听密友那样去倾听。说话者向你讲述了发生在他们身上的一个有意义的事件。然后你被告知，作为倾听者，要像倾听密友那样去倾听。在分心条件下，倾听者得到相同的指导，但也被告知，计算说话者
said a word that starts with th, that, this, those, you know, there are many words in the English language that start with th. So they cognitively distracted the listener. One interesting finding was that in the distraction condition, in the transcripts of the speakers, you could see a lot of the flow, the fluency of the speech was heard. So they went from there was no coherence in the story. So you start from the beginning to the end and then they went back to the middle. And a lot of stuttering, like, yeah. So this is remarkable because what you're saying is that the effects of poor listening were not experienced just by the listener. The effects of poor listening were not experienced just by the listener, the effects of poor listening were being experienced by the speaker. Exactly.
说以th开头的单词的次数，that, this, those，你知道的，英语中有许多以th开头的单词。所以他们在认知上分散了倾听者的注意力。一个有趣的发现是，在分心条件下，在说话者的文字记录中，你可以看到很多流畅度，说话的流畅度受到了损害。所以他们的故事没有连贯性。所以你从头讲到尾，然后他们又回到了中间。还有很多结巴，比如，yeah。所以这很了不起，因为你所说的是，糟糕倾听的影响不仅仅由倾听者体验到。糟糕倾听的影响不仅仅由倾听者体验到，糟糕倾听的影响正在由说话者体验到。完全正确。
And we have numerous experiments showing it. The listener determines more than 50% of the conversation. So the speaker's speech was heard, the fluency more stuttering. The most interesting in my view was that a few days afterwards, they invited the speakers back to tell about their own stories, the story that they told, and speakers who talked to distracted listeners remembered less from their own stories. And as a professor, I really resonate with it. For example, when I talk to a class and I see people not listening, you know, we have all these internal thoughts.
我们有大量实验表明这一点。倾听者决定了对话的50%以上。所以说话者的发言受到了影响，流畅度更差，结巴更多。在我看来最有趣的是，几天后，他们邀请说话者回来讲述他们自己的故事，他们讲过的故事，与分心倾听者交谈过的说话者对他们自己的故事记得更少。作为一名教授，我对此深有共鸣。例如，当我向全班讲话时，我看到人们没有在听，你知道，我们都有这些内心的想法。
And when we feel that the other person is not listening well to us, the volume of these internal thoughts goes up. You know, Guy, I was giving a talk recently at a university and there were, you know, a large number of people in the audience and the audience was very engaged and listening very closely. But there was one person in the audience, this is the end of the day, the person might have been tired, I might not have been as interesting as I thought I was, but the person was falling asleep and I could see the person from the stage, I could see this person falling asleep. Now it was a very large hall and they
当我们觉得另一个人没有好好听我们说话时，这些内心的想法的音量就会上升。你知道，盖伊，我最近在某所大学做了一场演讲，听众席上有很多人，听众非常投入，听得很仔细。但观众席里有一个人，这是在一天结束的时候，这个人可能累了，我也可能没有自己想象的那么有趣，但那个人睡着了，我从台上能看到这个人，我能看到这个人睡着了。现在那是一个非常大的礼堂，他们
were, most of the audience was very engaged, people were leaning forward, but the fact that one person was nodding off from the stage, I kept telling myself, you know, focus on everybody else who's listening, but my brain kept going back to this one person who was falling asleep. And it's a it's a very good example of what you're talking about, which is we're so sensitive to these markers that someone is not engaged with what we're saying and it really disrupts our own flow of thought. So your example is a great example of what's called the negativity bias in us. So you can have so many people listening to you, but you will focus on the one person that increases your evaluation and apprehension, the socially exclusion fear, which I think
大多数观众都非常投入，人们身体前倾，但由于一个人在打瞌睡这一事实，我在台上一直告诉自己，你知道，专注于其他所有在听的人，但我的大脑总是回到这个睡着的人身上。这是一个非常好的例子，说明了你所说的那种情况，即我们对别人没有参与我们谈话的这些迹象是如此敏感，以至于它真正打乱了我们自己的思维流程。所以你的例子很好地说明了我们身上所谓的消极偏差。所以你可以有那么多人听你说话，但你会专注于那一个人，这会增加你的评估和担忧，即社会排斥恐惧，我认为
is so fundamental, but I think your example says it the best. So you were recently having dinner with your family and a political issue came up. You told me some time ago that Israelis love to talk about politics and this probably was one of those examples. But in this situation you were trying to get your point across, but you felt you weren't being heard. Describe what happened to me and what the effect was on your ability to communicate your ideas, Guy. So, this was in a Passover dinner,
这是如此基础，但我认为你的例子表达得最好。所以你最近和家人一起吃晚饭，谈到了一个政治话题。你前不久告诉我，以色列人喜欢谈论政治，这可能就是其中一个例子。但在这种情况下，你想阐明你的观点，但你觉得没有被倾听。向我描述一下发生了什么，以及对你传达想法的能力产生了什么影响，盖伊。所以，这是在一次逾越节晚宴上，
and it was around a very, very heated topic back then. Now it seems like a different world now. It was about the radical reform that was supposed to happen in Israel. Many families were very divided, my family as well. You know, a Passover dinner is a dinner with many of the family you don't see very often. You know, there is a sentence, you don't speak politics at the dinner table, but this was a very, like, this was the only thing people talked about back then.
当时围绕着一个非常、非常激热的话题。现在回想起来，那似乎是一个不同的世界了。那是关于本应在以色列发生的激进改革。许多家庭非常分裂，我的家庭也是如此。你知道，逾越节晚宴是一场与许多不常见面的家人的晚宴。你知道，有这样一句话，饭桌上不谈政治，但这非常像，这是当时人们谈论的唯一事情。
And I actually didn't want to get into it because it was very sensitive topic. And there are family members who I see maybe once every two years. So like, I don't want to get into an argument with them. It doesn't do good for anyone. Not for me, not for them, not for the relationship. But they brought it up. One of them brought something up and I thought, okay, I'm not going to say anything until he said something I really opposed.
我其实不想介入其中，因为这是一个非常敏感的话题。有些家庭成员我可能每两年才见一次面。所以，我不想和他们争吵。这对任何人都没有好处。对我没有，对他们没有，对这段关系也没有。但他们提起了。其中一个人提起了某事，我想，好吧，我什么都不说，直到他说了一些我强烈反对的话。
And I couldn't, you know, it was like it's like someone hitting me in the stomach, like psychologically hitting me and like, and I responded, and then he responded. And then we got into this argument. And I felt that the more angry I got, the more my mind became narrow. I could only think of very weak arguments. And even when I conveyed the arguments, even to me, they sounded so weak. And then the frustration because I know so much, and now when I present my arguments, because I'm so mad, I can't even think straight.
我无法，你知道，这就像有人击中我的胃，像心理上击中我一样，我回应了，然后他回应了。然后我们陷入了这场争论。我觉得我越生气，我的思想就越狭隘。我只能想到非常薄弱的论点。甚至当我表达这些论点时，连我自己听起来都觉得那么无力。然后是沮丧，因为我知道得那么多，而现在当我陈述我的论点时，因为我太生气了，我甚至无法清晰思考。
So this was a very, even my wife told me afterwards, don't argue anymore like this. When you argue, you sound ignorant. And she knows how much I know, but nothing came out. And in some ways, this matches what you're finding in the lab, which is that when we have all these thoughts racing around in our heads, it keeps us from making the kinds of arguments we could have made if someone was actually listening well. these thoughts racing around in our heads, it keeps us from making the kinds of arguments we could have made if someone was actually listening well. That in some ways, the lack
所以这是一个非常，连我妻子事后都对我说，不要再这样争论了。当你争论时，你听起来很无知。她知道我知道多少，但什么也说不出来。在某些方面，这与你在实验室发现的一致，也就是当我们脑子里有所有这些思绪在赛跑时，它会阻止我们提出本可以提出的论点，如果有人真的好好听的话。这些思绪在我们脑海中奔涌，它阻止了我们提出本可以做出的论点，如果有人真的在好好倾听的话。在某种程度上，缺乏
of listening or the fact that we feel like we have to shout to get our view across actually makes our own arguments more impoverished than they would be otherwise. Exactly. Because in my story, for example, and I see it in the lab many times, when we feel that our right to express our attitude, perspective, belief is being threatened, we become defensive. And when we become defensive, we try to bolster our own attitudes. It makes the listening almost impossible when we're in such a state, because when, going back to this example, when this family member was speaking, I wasn't listening to him. I was thinking how I'm going to counter back. And when I was speaking, I saw he wasn't listening. He was thinking the same. So basically we were talking past each other. We both come away with a more rigid attitude. So it wasn't
倾听，或者我们觉得必须大喊大叫才能让自己的观点被听到，实际上让我们的论点比原本更加贫乏。完全正确。因为在我的故事中，例如，我在实验室里多次看到这一点，当我们觉得我们表达自己态度、视角、信念的权利受到威胁时，我们会变得具有防御性。当我们变得具有防御性时，我们就会试图巩固我们自己的态度。当我们处于这种状态时，倾听几乎是不可能的，因为当，回到这个例子，当这个家庭成员在说话时，我没有在听他说话。我在想我该如何反驳。当我在说话时，我看到他没有在听。他也在想同样的事情。所以基本上我们是在各说各话。我们两人的态度都变得更加僵化。所以这不是
a conversation. It was an exercise for both of us of how to bolster our attitude. And then people are surprised that polarization increases and people are becoming more extreme because we don't practice listening and we don't create the atmosphere, the openness that allows listening to happen. You say that another big reason that listening is hard is that we can be afraid of change. What do you mean by this guy? This is not my idea. This was suggested by Carl Rogers, one of the noted fathers of modern psychology. And Roger said that one of the reasons for our poor communication is that we fear that if we really listen, we might need to change. And when we are not the one who initiates the change, this can be threatening. Like for me, it would be conversing with my wife.
一次对话。这对我们俩来说都是一次如何巩固自己态度的练习。然后人们就会惊讶为什么两极分化加剧了，人们变得更加极端，因为我们不练习倾听，我们也没有营造出允许倾听发生的氛围和开放性。你说倾听很难的另一个重要原因是，我们可能害怕改变。盖伊，你这是什么意思？这不是我的想法。这是卡尔·罗杰斯提出的，他是现代心理学著名的鼻祖之一。罗杰斯说，我们沟通不畅的原因之一是，我们担心如果我们真的倾听，我们可能需要改变。而当我们不是发起改变的人时，这可能会带来威胁。就像对我来说，将是与我妻子交谈。
My wife is the person who knows me the best. We've been married last week, 13 years. We've been together 14 years. She knows me better than I know myself. She can predict my behavior when I tell her, no, I'm not gonna do that. She tells me, okay, you are gonna do that. And I said, no, I'm not gonna do it.
我妻子是最了解我的人。我们上周结婚13年了。我们在一起14年了。她比我自己更了解我。当我告诉她，不，我不会那样做时，她可以预测我的行为。她告诉我，好的，你会那样做的。我说，不，我不会去做的。
You'll see. And then I called her and say, well, okay, now I am. Yeah, I'm coming home early. I'm not going to do it, you'll see. And then I called her and say, well, okay, now I am. Yeah, I'm coming home early. I'm not going to the gym as I planned. So she knows me better than I know myself. So when she says something that bothers her about my behavior, I know that she's right. But it's not comfortable for me to hear it
你会看到的。然后我打电话给她说，好吧，好吧，我现在要去了。是的，我早点回家。我不会按计划去健身房。所以她比我更了解我自己。因此，当她谈到关于我的行为让她烦恼的事情时，我知道她是正确的。但这对我来说并不舒服去听到它，
because this is me. If I admit it, I basically admit that I need to change it. And well, a change is hard work. So in other words, I dig in more deeply into my preferred point of view because I'm worried that if I actually listen to you, I might have to change my beliefs. Yes. Think about a person who holds a very extreme position, a very one-sided view on any topic. Now, if this person really listens to someone who holds a different attitude,
因为这是我。如果我承认了，我基本上就是承认我需要改变。而改变是一项艰苦的工作。换句话说，我更深地陷入我偏好的观点中，因为我担心如果我真的听了你的话，我可能不得不改变我的信念。是的。想想一个持有极其极端立场、对任何话题都只有一面之词的人。现在，如果这个人真的倾听了一个持有不同态度的人，
they might realize that there is merit to the opposite point of view. Now, I'm not saying they will change the attitude, but if I'm extreme and this is a self-identifying attitude, I might realize that I need to change. Now then, how do I justify myself? How do I justify my behaviors? This defensiveness, this fear of change is something that is going with us in our daily lives. Guy, there was also a study that was conducted looking at managers in the workplace, and
他们可能会意识到对立的观点也有其可取之处。现在，我不是说他们会改变态度，但如果我是极端的，并且这是一种自我认同的态度，我可能会意识到我需要改变。那么，我该如何证明自己？我如何为自己的行为辩护？这种防御性，这种对改变的恐惧，是伴随着我们日常生活的东西。盖伊，还有一项针对职场经理的研究，
it found that sometimes managers are reluctant to listen because they worry that listening might imply compliance. Tell me about the study and what it found. It was a great study. The researchers conducted a qualitative study. They conducted interview with, I think it was bank workers, I know in the financial industry. They found employees confused listening
它发现有时经理们不愿意倾听，因为他们担心倾听可能意味着顺从。跟我讲讲这项研究以及它的发现。这是一项很棒的研究。研究人员进行了定性研究。他们对，我认为是银行员工，我知道是在金融行业进行了采访。他们发现员工将倾听
to complying with their requests. So for example, if you're my manager, and why am I asking you to take a few days off, you might listen well to me, but if you afterwards do not accept my request, there is a very good chance that I will say Shankar is not a good listener. Now even though you did listen to me, but I will confuse listening with compliance. And this often happens in asymmetric relationship when there is a power difference. So the listener is not only a conversation partner, but has also resources
与顺从他们的请求混淆了。例如，如果你是我的经理，为什么我请求你休假几天，你可能会很好地倾听我的请求，但如果你事后不接受我的请求，我很有可能会说尚卡尔不是一个好的倾听者。现在，尽管你确实听了我的话，但我会将倾听与顺从混淆。这种情况经常发生在存在权力差异的不对称关系中。因此，倾听者不仅是对话伙伴，还拥有
that the speaker wants. And this study nicely showed how there is a risk of being perceived showed how there is a risk of being perceived unfairly as a bad listener, even though the manager did listen, but did not comply. It doesn't happen all the time, but it does happen in the workplace. I also see it in my daily life. For example, I go to the supermarket and a few days ago I hear this mother saying to her son, you don't listen. I told you so many times, you can't get this candy. Now he listened to her. He just didn't agree with her. There's a difference. There's a difference. I have the same issue with my girls. So you didn't listen to me.
说话者想要的资源。这项研究很好地展示了存在被不公平地视为糟糕倾听者的风险，尽管经理确实听了，但没有顺从。这种情况并非时常发生，但在职场中确实会发生。我在日常生活中也能看到这一点。例如，我去超市，几天前我听到这位母亲对她的儿子说，你没有听。我跟你说过多少次了，你不能买这个糖果。现在他听了她的话。他只是不同意她的看法。这有区别。这有区别。我和我的女孩们也有同样的问题。所以你没有听我说话。
I asked you for this. Yeah, I listened to you, but I didn't accept what you said. Yeah. But I can see how this cuts both ways though, because from the employee's point of view, the employee feels my manager listened to me very carefully and then didn't exceed to my request. Maybe the manager didn't listen to me very carefully and then didn't exceed to my request, maybe the manager didn't listen to me very well. From the manager's point of view, you could say, if I listen very carefully to my employee,
我向你索要了这个。是的，我听了你说话，但我没有接受你所说的话。是的。但我可以看到这如何带来双向的影响，因为从员工的角度来看，员工会觉得我的经理非常仔细地听了我说话，然后没有答应我的请求。也许经理没有非常仔细地听我说话，然后没有答应我的请求，也许经理没有很好地倾听我。从经理的角度来看，你可以说，如果我非常仔细地倾听我的员工，
my employee is going to think that I agree with him or her, I should communicate right away that in fact I disagree and not listen very well because listening can inadvertently imply compliance. So I can see from both points of view how this ends up being poisonous. That's true because as you mentioned like you create an expectation that if you listen so attentively you saw the merit in the request and you're about to so you create expectation that you cannot meet. However, there is a positive side to it. I don't want to present listening as in I want to give you the
我的员工会认为我同意他或她的观点，我应该立刻传达事实上我不同意并且不要听得太仔细，因为倾听可能会无意中暗示顺从。所以我从双方的角度都能看出这最终如何变得具有毒性。确实如此，正如你所提到的，你产生了一种期望，即如果你如此专心地倾听，你就看到了请求中的优点，并且你即将这样做，所以你产生了你无法满足的期望。然而，这有积极的一面。我不想把倾听表现得好像，我希望给予它应有的尊重，因为虽然当你处于管理角色时，顺便说一句，你在组织层级中越高，你在工作日中花在倾听上的时间就越多，当你好好倾听时，这是另一项研究，但当你好好倾听你的员工时，他们更有可能理解你为什么不接受这个请求。所以这不是，我不想传达出这样一种观点，嗯，不要听，所以不要建立期望。它是关于清晰地传达期望，但倾听在这方面是一把双刃剑，我认为。人们经常认为，
respect it deserves because although when you're in a managerial role, and by the way, the higher in the hierarchy, in the organizational hierarchy you are, the more time you spend on listening during your work day, when you listen well, this is a different research, but when you listen well to your employee, there is a bigger chance that they will understand why you did not accept the request. So it's not, I don't want to come away as saying, well, don't listen, so don't build expectations. It's about communicating expectations clearly, but listening is a double-edged sword in this way, I think. People often think that
好好倾听某人或成为，其中一部分是对说话者不作评判，意味着他们必须同意说话者的观点。这是一个误解。良好的倾听并不等于同意。我可以对我的说话者不作评判，这意味着给予他们表达自己想法、观点的自由和自主权，这在当今是一个罕见的成分，同时仍然保持不同的态度。因此，不作评判和做一个好的倾听者并不意味着我需要同意。
listening well to someone or being, which part of it is being non-judgmental toward the speaker, means that they have to agree with the speaker. And this is a misperception. Good listening is not equal to agreement. I can be non-judgmental towards my speaker, which means giving them the freedom and autonomy to express what they think, their views, which nowadays is a rare ingredient, while still holding a different attitude. So being non-judgmental and a good listener does not mean that I need to agree.
所以同意不是良好倾听的先决条件。我们认为倾听是一种被动的活动，但正如盖伊的研究发现的那样，倾听一点也不被动。积极倾听和糟糕倾听都会传递信息。带有积极或灾难性后果的信息。当我们回来时，倾听的变革力量以及如何成为一个更好的倾听者。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
So agreement is not a prerequisite for good listening. We think of listening as a passive activity, but as Guy's research has found, listening is not passive at all. Both active listening and poor listening communicate messages. Messages with positive or disastrous consequences. When we come back, the transformative power of listening and how to be a better listener. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回想一下你上次与一个真正倾听你说话的人交谈的情景。你可能觉得自己被理解了。当你说话时，言语对你来说易如反掌。你觉得与另一个人的距离更近了。在海法大学，盖伊·伊齐科夫研究倾听的科学。盖伊，我们之前讨论过糟糕的倾听如何招致糟糕的倾听。当我们觉得有人没有在听
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Think about the last time you had a conversation with someone who really listened to you. You probably felt understood. As you spoke, the words came easily to you. You felt closer to the other person. At the University of Haifa, Guy Itzikov studies the science of listening. Guy, we've talked earlier about how poor listening can beget poor listening. When we don't feel like someone is listening to
我们说话时，我们听他们说话的可能性就会降低。但反过来也是如此。跟我讲讲你最近和一位同事的对话，他在政治上与你意见不合，但却是一个非常好的倾听者。所以这是一次非常近期的对话，大约在一周前。我们持有相反的观点。我们之前讨论过我和家人在一起时糟糕的倾听经历。现在，这完全相反。他真的很好地听我说话，尽管他完全不同意我所说的话。
us, we become less likely to listen to them. But the opposite is also true. Tell me about a recent conversation you had with a colleague who disagreed with you about politics but was a very good listener. So it was a very recent conversation about a week ago. And we hold opposite views. And we talked before about the poor listening experience I had with my family member. Now, this was the exact opposite. He really listened well to me, even though he completely disagreed with what I was saying.
而这一次我能清晰地思考。我能够以一种我实际上也能看到对立面的方式阐明我的论点。当我倡导赞成X时，我也能看到X的问题。它让我看到了我态度中的多面性，这与我在上一段争论中表达和感受到的单面性完全相反。他是一个很好的倾听者，他是一个很好的倾听者。他的非语言回应很好，保持了眼神交流，他提出了真正表明他试图理解我的观点的问题，尽管我知道他不同意。但我感到他并没有因为这种态度而评判我。我问了他问题，在他倾听了我之后，我更容易听他说话
And this time I could think clearly. I was able to articulate my arguments in a way that I was actually able to see also the opposite side. When I was advocating in favor of X, I could also see the problem with X. It allowed me to see the multiplicity within my attitude, which was the complete opposite of the one-sidedness that I expressed and felt during the argument in the previous segment. He was a great listener, he is a great listener. He responded both non-verbally, he kept eye contact, he asked questions that really showed that he's trying to get my point of view, even though I know he disagrees. But I felt that he doesn't judge me for this attitude. And I asked him questions and it was easier for me to listen to him after he listened
得这么好。而且我认为我在回听他方面做得很好。有趣的是，尽管我们谈论了一个如此两极分化且在这个话题上持有不同态度的选题，我们还是设法非常顺利地过渡到下一个话题，因为当我们讨论这个分裂的话题时，良好的倾听在场。我听说你做过一项具有类似发现的研究，表明良好的倾听可以让人变得更开明。
so well to me. And I think I did a good job in listening back to him. And the interesting thing is that although we talked about the topic that is so polarizing and we hold different attitudes on this topic, we managed to shift to the next topic like it was so smooth because good listening was present when we talked about this divisive topic. I understand that you've run a study with similar findings that shows that good listening can make people more open-minded.
对我来说非常好。我觉得我在回听他的话时做得很好。有趣的是，尽管我们谈论了一个如此极端化且双方持不同态度的议题，我们还是能够非常顺利地过渡到下一个话题，因为在我们探讨这个有争议的话题时，良好的倾听始终存在。据我了解，您曾做过一项研究，得出了类似的发现，即良好的倾听能让人变得更加思想开放。
Can you tell me about this research, Guy? Yeah, happy to. This was about listening during disagreements. So I will give you one example of one of the studies. It was a package of four experiments that we ran. Israel was the first country who implemented the vaccination cards during the pandemic. And this was a big issue because it divided the population to two. If you have the vaccination card, you can get to many places.
盖伊，你能跟我讲讲这项研究吗？好的，我很乐 the pleasure. 这是关于在意见不合时如何倾听的研究。所以我先给你讲讲其中一个研究的例子。这是我们开展的一系列四项实验。以色列是疫情期间第一个使用疫苗通行证的国家。这是一个重大问题，因为它将人口分成了两派。如果你有疫苗通行证，你可以去很多地方。
And if you don't have, there are many, many places. You remember how it was. And Israel, we were the first. There was a lot of divide around this topic. And during this time, we said, okay, this is the perfect time to do a study about it. So students sign up for this study. They first wrote and indicated their attitude
如果你没有，有很多很多地方你就去不了。你还记得当时的情况。在以色列，我们是第一个。这个话题周围有很大的分歧。在这个时期，我们说，好吧，这是做相关研究的最佳时机。因此，学生们报名参加了这项研究。他们首先写下并表明了自己的态度
if they are pro or against, or they hold a neutral position. They wrote a brief essay justifying their attitude. And then we told them that a few days later, they were going to be conversing with a listener. And so for example, if you indicated that you were against vaccination cards, you will be paired with a listener who supposedly was in favor. And we had my research assistants in my lab, they go through 15 to 20 hours of listening training, as they do both good listening condition and normal listening, or we call it moderate listening condition. And so the speakers share their attitudes, either randomly assigned to either
他们是赞成、反对还是持中立立场。他们写了一篇简短的文章来阐述自己的态度。然后我们告诉他们，几天后他们将与一位倾听者进行对话。例如，如果你表明你反对疫苗通行证，你将被配对给一位据推测是赞成该立场的倾听者。我们实验室的研究助理接受了15到20小时的倾听培训，他们同时进行良好的倾听条件和正常的倾听，或者我们称之为适度的倾听条件。因此，发言者分享他们的态度，随机分配给
with a listener who exhibited good listening behavior, such as their reflection, question asking, validation, which is something, which goes something like, thank you Shankar for sharing this with me, I'm sure it wasn't easy for you. And the listeners reminded them that they had an opposite attitude. Guy and his colleagues found that the better the listener, the greater the sense of warmth speakers felt when talking to them. But that's not surprising.
与表现出良好倾听行为的倾听者进行对话，例如他们的回应、提问、确认，这大概是这样的：谢谢你，尚卡尔，跟我分享这些，我相信对你来说这并不容易。倾听者提醒他们，他们有着相反的态度。盖伊和他的同事发现，倾听者越好，发言者在与他们交谈时感受到的温暖感就越强。但这并不令人惊讶。
What was surprising is that when paired with an excellent listener, speakers were more likely to moderate their views. They didn't shift their attitude, but they moved more towards the midpoint. So they did move towards the listener's attitude, but they still kept their own valence or positivity or negativity. Now, the most interesting thing was that we measured their attitude extremity, the extent to which their attitude is one-sided before the conversation and after. And the change was significantly greater in
令人惊讶的是，当与一位出色的倾听者配对时，发言者更有可能缓和他们的观点。他们没有改变自己的态度，但他们更多地向中间立场靠拢。所以他们确实朝着倾听者的态度转变了，但他们仍然保留了自己原有的效价、积极性或消极性。现在，最有趣的是，我们在对话前和对话后测量了他们的态度极端程度，即他们的态度是一元化（单方面）的程度。这种变化在
the high quality listening condition, meaning that their attitude became less one-sided. And we replicated this finding across four experiments, different topics. So this was a really interesting finding. Hmm. Hmm. You know, I'm thinking about that children's game that we all used to play, you know, where you have a rope and you're playing tug of war.
高质量倾听的条件下显著更大，这意味着他们的态度变得不再那么单一。我们在四个不同的实验和不同的主题中复制了这一发现。所以这是一个非常有趣的发。嗯。嗯。你知道，我在想我们以前都玩过的那种儿童游戏，你知道，就是你拿着一根绳子在玩拔河。
And of course you have these two sides lining up on opposite sides and, you know, you want to dig your heels into the ground and pull on the rope as hard as you can. And you obviously want to pull in only one direction, because of course if you give any ground then the other side is going to win. And you know of course as a metaphor, you know I'm wondering whether it fits the way many of us approach conversations, which is we are so intent on where that rope is, that we actually feel like we have to pull really hard in only one direction, because of course if we give any ground, then we're going to lose the battle altogether.
当然，这两边在相反的方向排好队，你知道，你想把脚跟深扎在泥土里，尽可能用力地拉绳子。你显然只想朝着一个方向拉，因为如果你退让了一点，另一方就会获胜。你知道，作为一个隐喻，你知道我在想这是否符合我们许多人对待对话的方式，那就是我们太执着于那根绳子的位置了，以至于我们实际上觉得自己必须只朝一个方向拼命拉，因为如果我们让步哪怕一点点，我们就会彻底输掉这场战斗。
But really what you're saying is that when one side stops pulling, and in some ways there's no more tug of war to be played because the other side is not pulling in the opposite direction, you're not just holding the rope now, and now it allows you to basically say, where do I actually wanna go with this rope? Do I wanna go in this direction? Do I wanna go in the other direction? You become more self-reflective. Yeah, I'm actually saying that if you listen well,
但实际上你所说的是，当一方停止拉绳子时，在某种程度上就不再有拔河比赛可玩了，因为另一方没有在相反方向拉，你现在不仅仅是在抓着绳子，这让你基本上可以思考：我到底想带着这根绳子去哪里？我想去这个方向吗？我想去另一个方向吗？你会变得更具反思性。是的，我实际上是在说，如果你好好倾听，
you will get a bigger rope. And there will be enough rope for both of you, and a mutual rope. Because you will see, you will be better able to see the needs and interest of your conversation partner. People often think that if they, they will be more effective if they dominate the conversation. So whoever speaks louder in Israel, it's very true. It's not true empirically, but it's true society-wise. If I speak louder, I'm dominating the conversation and then I'm
你会得到一根更大的绳子。你们俩会有足够的绳子，一根共同的绳子。因为你会看到，你会更好地看到你的对话伙伴的需求和利益。人们经常认为，如果他们这样做，如果他们在谈话中占主导地位，他们就会更有效率。所以在以色列，谁说话声音大，这非常真实。从实证上讲这不是真的，但从社会层面上讲它是真的。如果我说话声音更大，我就主导了对话，然后我
going to win. And that's another misperception. But it's not easy to tell a person, you need to let go. And if you let go and you really try to listen and understand your conversation partner, who you probably disagree with, it will be at your advantage. Both of your advantages, but it's not an easy decision because we're so used to try to dominate the conversation and afraid that if we want to dominate the conversation by speaking, we will lose. And then we end up by losing both of us. I mean, there's a great irony here, Guy, which is that very often when we find ourselves in
就会赢。这也是另一个误解。但要对一个人说“你需要放手”并不容易。如果你放手，真正努力去倾听和理解你的对话伙伴——你可能不同意他们的观点——这会对你有利。对你们双方都有利，但这不是一个容易的决定，因为我们习惯了试图主导对话，并害怕如果我们通过说话来主导对话而失败，我们会输。最后我们两败俱伤。我的意思是，这里有一个巨大的讽刺，盖伊，那就是通常当我们发现自己身处
disagreement with someone, we want them to basically say, you know, I'm open to new positions and new points of view. I'm willing to rethink my existing stance. And that's why we push so hard and we shout so loudly, is we're trying to knock people off from their positions to take a more broad-based view of things. What you're finding in some ways is that it's actually not our arguments that have this effect on people, it's our listening that can have this effect on people. So it's a great paradox that in fact, even if we were not focused on the quality of the relationship, if we were just focused on our goals of actually trying to knock people off from that point of view, we would be more effective if we actually did better listening
与某人意见不合时，我们希望他们基本上说：“你知道的，我对新的立场和新的观点持开放态度。我愿意重新考虑我现有的立场。”这就是为什么我们如此用力地推挤，如此大声地喊叫，我们试图把人们从他们的立场上撞下来，让他们对事物有更广泛的看法。你在某种程度上发现，实际上并不是我们的辩论对人们产生这种影响，而是我们的倾听能够对人们产生这种影响。这是一个巨大的悖论，事实上，即使我们不关注关系的质量，如果我们只是专注于试图把人们从那种观点上撞下来的目标，如果我们真正做好了倾听，我们会更有效率
and less arguing. I agree. I agree. So what I do with my students is I tell them a very simple task. Your goal for the upcoming week is to learn something new about a colleague of yours. One colleague each day. After each conversation, you need to reflect on your listening. What did you learn? What prevented you from listening well? What made you able to listen well? how can you improve the next time? So the gist is even forget all the behaviors.
而不是争论。我同意。我同意。所以我和我的学生做的是，我给他们布置一个非常简单的任务。你接下来一周的目标是了解你的一位同事的新情况。每天一个同事。每次对话后，你需要反思你的倾听。你学到了什么？是什么阻止了你好好倾听？是什么让你能够好好倾听？下次你该如何改进？所以重点是甚至忘记所有的行为。
If you truly are interested in a person, you will be probably perceived as a good listener because you will do all this behavior. So like think, for example, think of a person you love and this person comes and tells you, Shankar, I have something I want to share with you. You don't need me to tell you about what are the behaviors of good listening, and the verbal and the non-verbal.
如果你真的对一个人感兴趣，你可能会被认为是一个好的倾听者，因为你会做出所有这些行为。所以比如想一想，想想你爱的人，这个人来对你说：“尚卡尔，我有话想跟你分享。”你不需要我告诉你什么是良好倾听的行为，什么是言语和非言语的。
You're interested in this person. And your behaviors will reflect this interest. And this, I think, is at the core. So now we can't be interested in every person. But I think the basic premise is if we adapt a mindset that every person can teach us something, every person knows something that we've done, every person has a story. If you're interested in this story, you will most likely be perceived as a good listener. But at the same time, you know, I
你对这个人感兴趣。你的行为会反映出这种兴趣。我认为，这是核心所在。现在我们不可能对每个人都感兴趣。但我认为基本的前提是，如果我们采纳这样一种心态：每个人都能教给我们一些东西，每个人都知道一些我们做过的事，每个人都有一个故事。如果你对这个故事感兴趣，你很可能会被认为是一个好的倾听者。但与此同时，你知道，我
can imagine a situation where I'm speaking to somebody whom I like very much, we're in a very calm setting. There are not a lot of distractions. This person and I agree on a whole bunch of things. They're talking. I find listening to be effortless and easy, the conversation is great. Now, those situations do arise, they happen with regularity, hopefully more often than not, but really what we're called upon to do is situations
可以想象这样一种情况：我和一个我非常喜欢的人说话，我们在一个非常平静的环境中。没有太多的干扰。这个人我和在很多事情上都意见一致。他们在说话。我发现倾听毫不费力且轻松，谈话非常棒。现在，这些情况确实会出现，它们经常发生，希望这种情况多于不经常发生的情况，但实际上我们被要求去做的情况是
that in fact don't meet all of those criteria. We have to actually talk to people whom we might not be close to. We might be talking to them in environments that are noisy or distracted, and we might, most importantly, be talking to people whom we might not be close to. We might be talking to them in environments that are noisy or distracted. And we might, most importantly, be talking to people whom we disagree with. And at some level, I think what you're suggesting
实际上并没有满足所有这些标准。我们实际上不得不与那些可能与我们不亲密的人交谈。我们可能在嘈杂或嘈杂的环境中与他们交谈，最重要的是，我们可能在与那些我们可能不亲密的人交谈。我们可能在嘈杂或分心的环境中与他们交谈。最重要的是，我们可能在与我们意见不合的人交谈。在某种程度上，我认为你所暗示的是
is that we have to bring to bear the same skills that we extend to the people we love and that we agree with to the people that we don't love and don't agree with if we're gonna make any headway with them. Exactly. And this is why listening requires training, because for the people we love and are interested in, like you said, very easy. But the reality is that our life are filled with other people as well.
如果我们想在他们身上取得任何进展，我们就必须把我们对所爱之人和意见一致之人所展现的相同技能，运用到我们不爱的人和意见不合的人身上。完全正确。这就是为什么倾听需要训练，因为对于我们爱的人和感兴趣的人，就像你说的，非常容易。但现实是，我们的生活中也充满了其他人。
So this is why listening requires training and a decision to be a good listener. And it's really important, like we talked about being non-judgmental towards the speaker. Also, it's really important to be non-judgmental towards yourself when you realize that you might not be as good of a listener as you thought you are. Most of us are not as good of listeners as we think we are. But even if you are a good listener, Most of us are not as good of listeners as we think we are.
所以这就是为什么倾听需要训练和成为一个好倾听者的决心。这非常重要，就像我们谈到的对发言者不予评判一样。同样重要的是，当你意识到自己可能不像想象中那么会倾听时，对你自己也不要评判。我们大多数人都没有自己想象的那么会倾听。但即使你是一个好的倾听者，
But even if you are a good listener, there are times when we cannot be. As we mentioned, listening is a resource that we don't always have. You have talked about various techniques, and I know there's no sort of quick fix, sort of a guide to this, but I just want to talk about two or three important techniques that you and others have identified. Can you just talk about this idea that good listening involves a variety of verbal and nonverbal cues? What do you mean by this idea? What are some of these cues, Guy? So nonverbal behaviors are, for example, our facial expressions. Nonverbal behavior such as nodding, such as open body posture, eye contact is very important.
但即使你是一个好的倾听者，有时我们也做不到。正如我们所提到的，倾听是一种我们并不总是拥有的资源。你已经谈到了各种技术，我知道这没有什么快速解决的办法，也没有什么指南，但我只想谈谈你和其他人确定的两到三种重要技术。你能谈谈这个观点吗，即良好的倾听涉及各种语言和非语言线索？你对这个观点的理解是什么？其中有哪些线索，盖伊？所以非语言行为是，例如，我们的面部表情。非语言行为，例如点头，开放的身体姿势，眼神接触非常重要。
If the speaker sees that you are still paying attention to them, that you are still listening to them, you send them a meta-message. It's called a meta-message, not a direct message, but that you are important. You are the focus of my attention. I want to understand you. And this message relaxes them. They feel important. You are the focus of my attention. I want to understand you. And this message relaxes them. They feel important. They feel validated.
如果发言者看到你仍然在关注他们，你仍然在倾听他们，你就会向他们发送一条元信息。这被称为元信息，而不是直接信息，但它传达的是你很重要。你是我的注意力焦点。我想理解你。这个信息让他们放松下来。他们觉得自己很重要。你是我的注意力焦点。我想了解你。这个信息让他们放松下来。他们觉得自己很重要。他们感到被认可。
Now listening also has a verbal component and this is something that is less known because many think that listening is only silence. It's not. For example, paraphrase. So when the speaker stops and doesn't have any more to add or when you feel that you cannot encompass any more information, it's really important to reflect or paraphrase or summarize in your own words
现在，倾听也有一个言语组成部分，这是鲜为人知的，因为许多人认为倾听只是沉默。并非如此。例如，释义（复述）。所以当发言者停下来，没有什么可补充的时，或者当你觉得你无法容纳更多信息时，用你自己的话来反思、释义或总结是非常重要的
or if you can, the closest you can to the speaker's words. And it's really important to ask afterwards, did they miss anything? Would you like to add anything? And this paraphrasing, we find it in our experiment that is very powerful because it benefits both the listener and the speaker. It benefits the listener because the speaker tells you about points that you missed.
或者如果可以的话，尽量接近说话者的原话。事后问一句“有没有漏掉什么？你想补充点什么吗？”真的非常重要。我们通过实验发现，这种复述非常有力，因为它对倾听者和说话者都有益。它对倾听者有益，因为说话者会告诉你那些你遗漏的要点。
And there are studies showing that even good listeners remember up to 50% of the content. So no one expects us to remember everything. So it helps the listener. Most importantly, it helps the speaker to feel understood what people usually do and say, yeah, Shankar, I understand you. That doesn't work. It's like me telling you, Shankar, trust me.
研究表明，即使是优秀的倾听者，最多也只能记住百分之五十的内容。所以没有人期望我们能记住所有事情。这对外倾听者有帮助。最重要的是，它有助于让说话者感到被理解。人们通常的做法和说法是，是的，尚卡尔，我理解你。那样是没用的。这就好像我对你说，尚卡尔，相信我一样。
I can tell you to trust me. I need to show you that you can trust me. So by reflection, I show you, I try to understand you. Another one is asking good questions that benefit the speaker's needs and interests. Very, very important. Good questions can deepen the conversation and help speakers bring from within them insight that they didn't think that they about before. Validation which is not, yeah, Shankar, I agree with you.
确认并不是“是的，尚卡尔，我同意你的看法”。
Validation is especially in difficult conversation. Thank you for sharing with me, Shankar. I'm sure it wasn't easy for you. So it validates the effort that the speakers made and brings about closeness between the speaker and the exam. So I'm wondering, Guy, after doing all of this research and thinking, has it changed the way that you have tried to listen to other people? Do you find yourself doing poor listening and telling yourself, here are the things
确认尤其是在艰难的对话中。“谢谢你与我分享，尚卡尔。我确信这对你来说并不容易。”因此，它确认了发言者所做出的努力，并拉近了发言者和（倾听者）之间的亲近感。所以我想知道，盖伊，在做了所有这些研究和思考之后，它改变了你试图倾听别人的方式吗？你是否发现自己有糟糕的倾听行为，并告诉自己，这里有这些事情
that I can do? Have you found yourself mid-conversation, stopping yourself to try and practice what you preach? I think so. Last year in a class, there was a student who was very frustrated. And she came to me at the end of the lesson and she complained about the tasks and about how they don't have enough time. And students have a variety of complaints.
我可以做？你是否发现在谈话中途，自己停下来试图践行你所宣讲的理念？我想是的。去年在课堂上，有一个学生非常沮丧。她在课后找到我，抱怨作业以及他们没有足够的时间。学生们有各种各样的抱怨。
And I didn't try to justify myself. And I initially wanted to, because I was tired, it was a four-hour course, and then I decided to practice what I preach. And I did not defend myself. I asked follow-up questions. Okay, so I heard you're saying that this course is, you feel that even though I reduce the number of articles, this is still unfair. Why do you feel it? Do you have anything else? And at the end of the day, she shared with me that she was very frustrated because her boyfriend broke up with her and she was very angry. And she took it out on many people around her. She knew she was upset about the breakup with the boyfriend but she was actually hurting a lot because she
我没有试图为自己辩解。我最初想这么做，因为我累了，这是一门四个小时的课程，然后我决定践行我所宣讲的理念。我没有为自己辩解。我问了后续的问题。好吧，我听到你说这门课程，你觉得尽管我减少了文章数量，这仍然不公平。你为什么会有这种感觉？你还有别的吗？而在一天结束时，她跟我分享说她非常沮丧，因为她的男朋友和她分手了，她非常生气。她把气撒在了身边很多人身上。她知道自己对男友的分手感到不安，但实际上她受了很大的伤，因为她
was extrapolating the anger to the people around her family, even like professors, university, friends. And she told me like after our conversation it really helped me to relax, to unwind and And this made my day. Look at how this made my day that I managed to really help her and again, notice the power of listening. It's not easy. It's not easy. Every day is a challenge, but I do want to believe that I'm making progress. Guy Itzikoff is a psychologist at the University of Haifa. Guy, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a real pleasure to listen to you. Thank you very much for having me.
将这种怒气泛化到了周围的人身上，比如家人，甚至教授、大学、朋友。她对我说，在我们的谈话之后，这真的帮我放松了下来，解开了心结，这让我的一天都变得美好了。看，我成功地帮助了她，这让我的一天变得多美好，再次注意倾听的力量。这并不容易。这并不容易。每一天都是挑战，但我确实想相信我正在取得进步。盖伊·伊茨科夫是海法大学的心理学家。盖伊，非常感谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。听你分享真是太愉快了。非常感谢邀请我。
You're a very good listener. Thank you, Guy. Thank you. It's a professional occupation. Professional occupation, yes. so people will listen. If you're already a subscriber, it's available right now in this feed. If not, you can listen to that story as part of a free trial subscription on Apple Podcasts, or by going to apple.co.slash
你是个很好的倾听者。谢谢你，盖伊。谢谢。这是一项职业。职业，是的。这样人们就会倾听。如果你已经是订阅者，现在就可以在这个订阅源中收听。如果没有，你可以通过Apple Podcasts上的免费试用订阅来收听该故事，或者访问apple.co.slash
hiddenbrain. It was so easy to listen to it and time just flew by. Listening requires a lot of effort. I didn't feel that I'm making any effort in listening to it because it was so interesting. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy,
hiddenbrain。听这个节目太轻松了，时间不知不觉就过去了。倾听需要付出很多努力。我在听这个节目时并没有觉得自己在付出任何努力，因为它太有趣了。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、
Annie Murphy-Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Burns, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains' executive editor. If you'd like to hear more of our reporting about how to engage productively with others, be sure to check out the episode notes for today's show. You'll find other Hidden Brain interviews that will help you understand how conversations go off the rails, the role of good listening and successful relationships, and how we can keep conflicts from spiraling. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯蒂安·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、赖安·卡茨、奥特姆·伯恩斯、安德鲁·查德维克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你想听到更多关于如何与他人进行富有成效互动的报道，请务必查看今天节目的剧集说明。你会发现其他《隐藏的大脑》采访，它们将帮助你理解对话是如何脱轨的，良好倾听在成功关系中的作用，以及我们如何防止冲突螺旋式升级。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。